[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines au
menu de l'actualité des infos pratiques
et des idées de sortie voici le
programme de ce lundi 19 juin
l'actualité des dernières heures dans
les Yvelines les communes étaient
mobilisées pour les commémorations de
l'appel du 18 juin le trophée de la
Coupe du monde de rugby a été présenté à
Versailles ou encore une nouvelle maison
de santé sur le territoire on fait le
point en début d'édition un premier
Grand Prix de karting de 50 ans en
Yvelines c'était vendredi sur le circuit
Jean-Pierre Beltoise à trappe près de
200 personnes issues des entreprises et
écoles du territoire se sont affrontés
la victoire est revenue au pilote de la
section karting du Crédit Agricole sport
qui sont nos invités la team TV 78 était
également lisse nous verrons nous ferons
vivre les coulisses de cet événement et
puis un air de vacances à la plage à
flotter dans le département une semaine
du beach volley se déroulait durant tout
le week-end à Saint-Germain-en-Laye est
découverte de la discipline pratiquant
du sport ou encore match de haut niveau
était au programme retour dans la partie
sport du 7 8 et ce sera avec le retour
de Michael ennemi Doro sur le plateau de
TV 78 bonsoir Michael bonsoir comment
allez-vous je vais très bien je
suis pas très très reposé je vais vous
dire pourquoi je viens d'avoir mon
deuxième enfant et merci beaucoup et
voilà les nuits sont quand même un petit
peu courtes entre 5 et 6 heures mais ça
va il est mignon donc on lui pardonne on
lui parle encore félicitations et avec
vous c'est bien sûr les résultats sport
qu'il faut retenir du weekend des
derniers jours également dans dans le
département des Yvelines on parle de
quoi ce soir on parlera notamment de
handball il y a eu les finales des
coupes des Yvelines qui sont organisées
le week-end dernier cet état Élancourt
une vingtaine d'équipes une quarantaine
d'équipes se sont affrontés lors de ce
rendez-vous on parlera également de
Arthur et knocknech le Saint-Germain
nois qui en tennis a participé au
tournoi du Queen s'il a été
malheureusement éliminé et il y aura
plein d'autres choses à raconter
notamment des invités on va parler rugby
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'il y a la
Coupe du monde de rugby en France qui
approche le soir on va revenir on l'a
noté on va revenir sur la saison d'un
club divin on va se projeter aussi sur
les prochains mois la saison à venir
pour le plaisir Rugby Club qui s'est
pour l'équipe senior jusqu'au 16ème de
finale de Fédérale 2 et ce sera avec eux
vous tirez la mandé bonsoir président du
plaisir Rugby Club un mot une phrase
peut-être pour qualifier cette saison du
plaisir ubic club il n'y a pas que les
seniors on parlera aussi des jeunes et
de la section féminine tout à l'heure
saison exceptionnelle parce que les deux
équipes qualifiées en senior et puis
également les cadets juniors ont fait
des beaux parcours et voir les minimes
qui ont fait des finales fédérales on en
dit un peu plus tout à l'heure sur cette
saison du plaisir Rugby club et je le
disais en plateau les vainqueurs alors
il y en a un ce soir de la section
karting de du Crédit Agricole sport
vainqueur donc du premier trophée
karting de 50 ans en Yvelines c'était
organisé vendredi du côté du circuit
Jean-Pierre Beltoise à trappe et c'est
Fabrice canard qui est avec nous bonsoir
vous êtes membre de cette section
quartier bah quels sont vos impressions
là on est trois jours après cette
victoire de ce premier Grand Prix du
karting de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
c'était animé disputé et très
enrichissant parce qu'il y avait pas que
le karting il y avait pas que le karting
avait une journée effectivement dédiée à
la conduite dans sa globalité on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir on aura un long
retour avec Nicolas dandry notamment et
aussi vous Mathilde Franco bonsoir de la
rédaction TV sandwich on a participé en
inside on va le dire à ce trophée de
karting mais vous allez aussi nous
présenter dans un instant les
informations du jour ce qu'il faut
retenir de l'actualité des dernières
heures dans les Yvelines et ce sera
juste après un coup d'oeil aux
prévisions météo de demain
tout comme aujourd'hui ce sera plutôt
nuageux dans la matinée Yves linoise il
fera déjà chaud et lourd demain avec 21
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 20 degrés à
Versailles ou dans 19 degrés à
Rambouillet conséquence le ciel sera
orageux dans l'après-midi pas de pluie
annoncé pour autant pour le moment côté
température comptait 25 degrés dans les
secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan 24
degrés à Versailles Rambouillet et
demain mardi 20 juin ce sera la saint
Sylvère on fait le point tout de suite
sur l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
actualités du jour Mathilde avec
l'ouverture ce lundi de la 54e édition
du Salon International de l'Aéronautique
et de l'Espace ça se passe au Bourget
bien sûr tout à fait Grégory est dans
les Yvelines nous avons environ 300
entreprises qui év
oluent et le grand groupe comme safran
Airbus Ariane ou encore Thalès seront
présents jusqu'à dimanche 25 juin sur
place également nos confrères de radio
sensation Alexandra Dublanche a répondu
aux questions de Jessie Willens écoutez
l'aéronautique spatial défense est une
fille absolument stratégique pour
l'Île-de-France nous sommes la première
région aéronautique de France on
l'oublie un peu en nombre d'emplois
c'est une filière absolument cruciale
donc pour pour l'emploi et pour la
croissance de l'Île-de-France avec des
enjeux majeurs qui sont bien sûr la
décarbonation de cette industrie avec
tout un tas de solutions qui sont aussi
présentées au Bourget et également les
enjeux de souveraineté comment
relocaliser de la production sur notre
territoire et donc la région est un très
fort soutien de cette filière c'est à
peu près plus de 20 millions d'euros 21
millions d'euros qui ont été investis
depuis 2019 par la région dans cette
filière notamment sur les sujets
d'innovation et de décarbonation
et notre journaliste Nicolas dandry
journaliste économique sera également
sur place cette semaine il partira à la
rencontre de plusieurs chefs
d'entreprises dans les domaines de
l'aéronautique du spatial et de la
défense des interviews à retrouver dans
une émission spéciale du skyeko la
direction Poissy à présent ou un jeune
de 20 ans a été interpellé il a menacé
les deux morts le député car l'olivier
vin je le déteste je vais le suicider
devant chez lui à 14h02 voilà le message
que le jeune de 20 ans a publié sur
Twitter samedi dernier les policiers ont
réussi à l'identifier grâce à son
adresse
IP le député de la douzième
circonscription des Yvelines car le
livre déplore la hausse de ses menaces
selon lui c'est la troisième fois en
trois ans qu'il est menacé de mort selon
une enquête de l'association des mers
d'Île-de-France 70% des élus interrogés
disent avoir déjà subi une agression
physique ou verbale le département des
Yvelines est un territoire classé désert
médical selon l'agence régionale de
santé Île-de-France effectivement
Grégory est pour pallier le manque de
médecins le l'appartement s'est fixé
l'objectif d'ouvrir 22 maisons médicales
d'ici 2025 samedi dernier une nouvelle a
été inaugurée à Beynes au sein du
bâtiment 4 pôles sont prévus médical et
infirmiers kinésithérapie dentaire ainsi
que podologue et paramédical cette
nouvelle maison médicale et pour le
moment occupée à 75 % la ville cherche
encore des médecins des spécialistes et
des kinésithérapeutes c'est coût total
de l'opération 3,1 million d'euros
l'actualité des dernières heures hier
nous étions le 18 juin c'est une date
importante bien sûr pour la France quoi
qu'il arrive la flamme de la résistance
française ne doit pas s'éteindre et ne
s'éteindra pas voici une partie du
célèbre discours du Général de Gaulle
depuis Londres via la radio BBC c'était
le 18 juin 1940 83 ans plus tard les
communes yvelinoises commémore toujours
cet appel à la résistance nazie hier la
verrière mord pas Coignières et le
Mesnil Saint-Denis ce sont rassemblés
pour se souvenir ensemble depuis
l'origine depuis 1947 même si on ne
célébrait pas en 1947 le 18 juin mais la
destruction du char le sanglier de la
deuxième dB là au carrefour de la
malmodonne et bien c'est depuis 1983
qu'on célèbre effectivement le 18 juin
officiellement ici on le fait avec les
trois communes qui à l'origine célébrait
la destruction du char le sanglier
c'est-à-dire la verrière Maurepas le
Mesnil-Saint-Denis puisque un soldat
d'ailleurs décédé dans cette destruction
du char est enterrée dans le cimetière
du mini de Saint-Denis et Coignières
bien évidemment
un mot de sport à présent avec le
trophée de la Coupe du monde de rugby
qui est passé ce week-end par les
Yvelines il a été présenté à l'occasion
d'un tournoi caritatif de rugby organisé
hier à Versailles le public a pu
découvrir en exclusivité le trophée de
la Coupe du monde de rugby et le tout
nouveau président de la Fédération
française de rugby était également
présent pour l'événement écoutez on est
à moins de 90 jours de la Coupe du monde
qui va être un événement exceptionnel et
moi je suis très attentif à ce que cette
coupe du monde bénéficie à l'ensemble de
nos 195 clubs c'est un coup de
projecteur sur la ville ça aussi ici à
Versailles un club le Rugby Club de
Versailles avec un président Éric
Tournier Olivier mer 9 à ses côtés qui
est un historique du club qui font un
boulot considérable moi c'est c'est un
club exemplaire en tout point de vue
puisque il est formateur il est
développeur il agit aussi sur la
citoyenneté donc voilà c'est ça fait une
raison de plus de venir ici à Versailles
et les Yvelines seront au cœur de cette
coupe du monde de rugby puisque deux
villes seront camp de base Croatie sur
scène accueillera l'équipe du Tonga et
Versailles accueillera l'équipe du Pays
de Galles la ville royale passe en mode
rugby l'équipe de garde donc sera
présente à Versailles et on les a déjà
vu venir en mairie et
c'était très sympathique alors il y
avait pas tous les jours maintenant
uniquement le staff et c'était une belle
occasion d'échanges avant qu'il vienne
donc presque deux mois à Versailles on
va profiter des entraînements on est en
train d'organiser également des
événements avec eux
bon l'idée c'est que les Marseillais
puissent participer localement à cette
Coupe du monde à travers bien sûr la
présence du Pays de Galles et donc je le
disais à l'instant le trophée web hélice
a été présenté à l'occasion d'un tournoi
caritatif le 7 de cœur organisé depuis
10 ans il réunit chaque année 600
joueurs et des milliers de spectateurs à
l'issue environ 120000 € ont été
retransmis à 5 associations
engouement énorme aussi de du côté du
plaisir ubic club à l'approche de cette
Coupe du Monde oui oui c'est ça bon
après les actions seront à mettre en
place mais c'est ça même beaucoup de
monde sur le club on va poursuivre
Mathilde avec notre chiffre du jour 180
pourquoi 180 180 Grégory c'est le nombre
de collégiens qui se sont rendus
vendredi dernier au campus des sciences
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines il s'agit
spécifiquement des élèves de Georges
Clémenceau à Mantes-la-Jolie de René
Cassin à Chanteloup-les-Vignes et
d'Albert Thierry halimet ils ont pu
assister à cette conférence odeur à la
loupe l'alchimie des parfums d'Olivier
David enseignant chercheur l'objectif
leur faire découvrir les sciences et le
monde de l'enseignement supérieur depuis
2017 le campus des sciences de
Versailles s'engage à favoriser la
poursuite d'études scientifique et porte
une attention particulière à la parité
homme-femme dans le domaine scientifique
et puis on termine avec une image
impressionnante hier soir les Yvelines
ont essuyé de violents orages avec de
fortes pluies effectivement Grégory ce
qui a entraîné des inondations un peu
partout dans le département la route
nationale N118 par exemple était sous
l'eau vous le voyez sur ces images une
cuvette c'est même formée vous le voyez
au niveau de Bièvre plusieurs personnes
ont du même descendre de leur véhicule
pour le pousser car le moteur était sous
l'eau
piloter un karting avec des conditions
pareilles
on le fait sous la pluie mais là c'est
pas possible
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les Yvelines
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
[Musique]
mais dans l'actualité également jusqu'au
25 juin ce sont les journées
d'architecture à vivre demain mardi
justement l'architecte Philippe Madec
donnera une conférence à joueur
Pontchartrain il est l'auteur du
Manifeste pour la frugalité heureuse
Elizabeth Roja Lefebvre qui est
directrice du conseil d'architecture
d'urbanisme et de l'environnement des
Yvelines présente cet événement c'est un
architecte qui depuis longtemps et c'est
de réduire son empreinte carbone quand
il construit et avec deux autres
architectes et bureau d'études il a
inventé ce manifeste qui a été signé
maintenant par 15000 personnes en France
le CIA adhéré tout de suite à cette
démarche et on essaie de faire en sorte
que le réseau des personnes intéressées
par la frugalité augmente petit à petit
parce que construire de manière frugale
c'est utiliser les produits de la terre
intelligemment d'accord
recycler ou construire avec des
matériaux recyclables
tendance enfin des des penseurs de
l'écologie d'arriver à une comme dans la
nature dans la nature rien ne se perd et
c'est un peu ça
en ce moment est en train de construire
une école à Achères qui est en
construction bois et paille et on a fait
déjà visiter lors de nos échos
rencontres on organise les autres qu'on
rencontre toute l'année et cette école
sera particulièrement frugale dans ces
matériaux dans sa manière de consommer
ensuite du chauffage
tout est fait de manière à ce que il y
ait le moins de chauffage possible et le
moins de de climatisation
de se rafraîchir ou de retrouver
vous disiez l'école c'est bois et paille
c'est quoi les matériaux
qui qui incarne la frugalité alors la
terre aujourd'hui on utilise beaucoup la
terre par exemple la terre extraite du
Grand Paris Express ce grand tunnel qui
est construit qui est qui est décaissé
et dont la terre est réemployée pour
fabriquer de la brique qui est utilisée
pour construire la fabrique de terre
s'appelle cyclother et elle est à Sevran
donc il est possible d'aller visiter
cette
usine finalement de briques de terre
alors c'est une petite usine évidemment
mais c'est ce sont des architectes qui
ont proposé au grand à la Société du
Grand Paris de fabriquer ces briques de
terre à partir de la terre extraite de
leur chantier du Grand Paris
émission complète du vypr retrouvé sur
notre site Internet TV 78.com
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines organisés
vendredi dernier son premier Grand Prix
de karting c'était au circuit
Jean-Pierre Beltoise de trappe 50
entreprises école et start-up du
territoire ont participé à ce
rendez-vous les gagnants la section
karting du Crédit Agricole sport l'un
des membres justement de cette section
Cartier est avec nous je le disais en
début d'émission c'est Fabrice canard et
parmi les participants aussi il y avait
une team TV 78 vous en faisiez partie
Mathilde mais aussi Nicolas dandry
bonsoir la rédaction TV 78 ce qu'on va
revenir sur ce trophée vous étiez aussi
dans l'équipe on pose à trio exactement
comme toutes les équipes d'ailleurs qui
participaient à ce grand prix pour nous
comme pour notre invité d'ailleurs il y
a eu une journée qui a commencé par
trois ateliers de formation à la
conduite nous avons commencé avec un
exercice sur l'éco-conduite c'est-à-dire
sur la manière d'économiser de l'essence
en conduisant sur une partie du circuit
il fallait rouler en moyenne à 40 km/h
et Stéphane gressin nous donne justement
quelques astuces s'écouter le Conseil
principal ce serait quoi regardez loin
bien anticiper les événements
d'accélérer le moins souvent possible
tout en maintenant une un dynamisme et
une inertie qui nous permettra de rouler
sans gêner bien entendu alors participé
à cet exercice je sais pas comment ça
s'est passé pour vous alors très bien
découvertes et c'était c'était vraiment
intéressant de d'économiser du carburant
c'est important pour tous et vraiment
c'était c'était bien enrichissant je
suis assez fier parce que j'ai fait
quand même une moyenne de 42 km/h et
j'ai réussi à faire en fait 5,7 l pour
100 km le meilleur score de la journée
je crois l'un des meilleurs ratios ceux
qui avaient trouvé le véhicule donc je
suis assez fier là-dessus deuxième
exercice de conduite c'est le freinage
d'urgence et là je vous propose de
regarder cette extrait c'est avec vous
mais Mathilde regardez là on se lance 80
km heure la vitesse est marquée au
niveau du tableau de bord et en fait je
vais devoir freiner lorsque
je j'apercevrai le mannequin qui est
derrière le SAMU d'ailleurs vous me
direz à quel moment vous le voyez si
vous voulez
d'accord donc 80 il est derrière sa mue
voilà
vous avez pas vu le mannequin ah oui il
va pas être content
et oui ça peut arriver sur la route donc
ça veut dire là à 80 je peux pas
m'arrêter ça veut dire que vous l'avez
il était où le mannequin Mathilde il
était très bien caché le mannequin
Nicolas alors en quoi consistait cet
exercice parce qu'il y avait pas
uniquement le fait de d'observer de
découvrir qu'il y avait un mannequin
derrière le véhicule il fallait tester
les freins du véhicule et du coup se
rendre compte de l'entière capacité de
freinage de son véhicule et c'était un
exercice très intéressant parce que même
moi j'avais pas la connaissance qu'on
pouvait freiner aussi fort et aussi
rapidement et il y avait un second
exercice c'était freiné sur un terrain
mouillé et du coup ne pas écraser un
plot ce que j'ai plutôt bien réussi mais
c'était aussi un exercice un fort en
adrénaline Grégory mais c'est vrai quand
on est sorti de la voiture on était un
peu voilà je pense que c'est le terme
qu'on est sorti là c'est bah le pic
d'adrénaline avec avec ce freinage
d'urgence effectivement avec ces deux
scénarios il y avait
le mannequin qui arrive au dernier
moment finalement c'était le temps de
réaction qu'on testait plus et là après
le freinage sur route mouillé c'est vrai
que moi je croyais on sortait vider un
peu de cet atelier je sais pas ce que
vous en avez pensé Fabrice canard c'est
vrai on vit pas ces moments-là tous les
jours et heureusement d'ailleurs et
c'est curieux de de pouvoir freiner
aussi fort y compris sur le mouillé avec
avec la direction du véhicule qui prend
tout de suite alors on pensait qu'on
allait déraper et finalement non pas du
tout vraiment vraiment c'était bien
alors dernière atelier justement vous en
parliez Grégory et en plus c'est vous
qui avez fait cet exercice le temps de
réaction tester le temps de réaction via
un simulateur de conduite avec
différents scénarios et bien oui
effectivement il y avait différents
scénarios avec peut-être des surprises
qui apparaissent sur la route des des
véhicules qui grillent la priorité et là
faut savoir réagir de la bonne manière
et c'est vous Grégory qui avait fait cet
atelier d'ailleurs nous avons demandé au
formateur Franck brégion de faire un
bilan sur votre attitude Grégory a été
bon parce que effectivement je pense que
bah comme tout à chacun quand on se met
dans l'ordinateur on essaye de faire
bien en fait donc
d'avoir une attitude la mieux possible
en même si c'est pas même s'il n'a pas
été parfait dans le cas de Grégory au
moins il met des choses en place et même
si c'est pas parfait le fait de mettre
des choses en place bah ça améliore les
choses et c'est ce qu'on veut même si
bon voilà pour son ego alors peut-être
voulu complètement s'arrêter avant la
voiture mais au moins ça tape pas fort
et c'est ce qu'on veut ce qu'on veut
c'est pas jouer sa vie sur la route
c'est voilà c'est tant pis ça tape mais
ça tape pas fort mon idée c'est de de
tendre vers ça mais au moins le peu de
choses qu'on met en place au moins
s'améliorera chose et c'est ça qu'on
veut absolument bravo bravo Grégory
merci mais après oui c'est vrai que
c'était pas évident le fait d'être sur
un simulateur ça peut laisser un petit
peu pantois au début le fait aussi qu'on
soit observé d'ailleurs on a
l'impression de repasser son permis mais
après comme le disait très bien le
formateur il s'agit de sécurité routière
de scénario qui peuvent se présenter où
il faut mettre en place des choses pour
éviter justement les draps le pire c'est
ça exactement et alors l'après-midi
Grégory et bien c'était consacré à la
course de karting d'abord avec une phase
de qualification pour déterminer le
placement sur la grille et un départ
donné façon 24 Heures du Mans entre 1925
et 1969 vous le voyez les véhicules sont
garés et bien en épi les pilotes sont en
face j'ai pris le départ pour l'Équipe
TV 78 très très belle course j'ai
accéléré de toutes mes forces et puis en
fait il faut prendre le kart et puis
partir ensuite et après je vous laisse
savourer ces images regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment une belle découverte pour moi
le karting franchement c'était une
première et je me suis bien amusé
j'en ai bien transpiré c'est très très
physique je pense que on est tous
fatigués allez se reposer je pense
effectivement on a bien dormi après
j'ai bien aimé votre regard déterminé
Grégory sur Limoges non mais en plus
pour moi c'était la troisième fois que
je faisais je faisais du quartier on a
senti une progression tout au long de la
journée bon le résultat 14e est dû il
faut le préciser on a fait une erreur de
stratégie on va pouvoir la débriefer
avec Fabrice canard on a fait un sixième
changement alors qu'on avait 5
changements obligatoires le sixième nous
a fait perdre du temps et en plus de ça
on l'a fait dans une limite de temps
trop rapide ce qui fait qu'au final on a
on a pris un tour de pénalité on était
de du top 10 on a fini 14e
c'est que le passage au stand devait
être fait obligatoirement dans un chrono
en fait de 30 secondes minimum et donc
nous on a fait 26 secondes sur le
dernier relais et donc et alors vous
avez vu le trophée le trophée de numéro
1 c'est notre invité qui l'a emporté
c'était quoi votre stratégie finalement
sur cette course elle est vite très vite
et toujours très vite maintenant mais
pas par rapport au changement par
exemple
on a l'habitude un petit peu de courir
et en vérité on a fait trois relais de
30 minutes plutôt que plutôt que 6
relais d'un quart d'heure et on a fait
nos deux changements à la suite et voilà
ça nous permet de continuer sur le même
rythme toujours
le sixième changement qu'on a fait
erreur fatale ça vous fait perdre 30
secondes d'office et donc ça il faut
surtout pas faire il faut faut faire
juste les cinq les cinq arrêts
nécessaires
faisait 30 minutes de course à la fin il
n'était pas fatigué faisait pas des
erreurs
du karting
transpirant de la même façon que vous
c'est vrai 1h30 c'est ça paraît très
long enfin c'est très long pour le coup
et pour 1h30 de course pour des non
habitués à dire au karting c'est vrai
que c'était compliqué alors vous avez
donc terminé premier de la compétition
parce que c'est une compétition en
équipe on le disait il y avait trois
pilotes par par équipe même si c'est un
pilote de l'ESTACA qui a remporté la la
dernière course je crois qu'il fait les
championnats du monde d'ailleurs
finalement c'est c'est l'équipe qui a
primé c'est la stratégie c'est la
stratégie de l'équipe c'est c'est enfin
on a une équipe complémentaire assez
homogène et c'est ça qui est qui a fait
que qu'on a gagné c'est les valeurs de
l'enfance de l'entreprise d'ailleurs
maintenant une personne toute seule peut
pas tout peut pas tout faire quoi le
niveau de la finale vous l'avez trouvé
comment ah assez élevé d'ailleurs
la personne qui a gagné la finale
justement
[Musique]
assez facilement alors il y avait
l'équipe Crédit Agricole il y avait
l'équipe Renault aussi qu'on voyait
passer sur le côté et effectivement
alors justement vous parlez d'entreprise
est-ce que vous avez ce jour-là créer
des liens parce que c'était le but aussi
de la journée c'était que les acteurs
économiques se rencontrent est-ce que
vous avez discuté avec d'autres
entreprises peut-être des écoles aussi
d'ailleurs et les ateliers du matin dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure on a discuté
avec les deux équipes d'étudiants donc
ESTACA justement qui qui avait leur
pilote un peu un peu plus
et puis ISM aussi qui finit 3e de notre
de notre poule et bon voilà on a discuté
un petit peu de l'ambiance qu'il y avait
sur le circuit mais aussi de des
entreprises et de ce qui est recherché
j'ai pas réussi à le recruter
et du coup c'est votre section la
section karting qui a remporté ce
premier Grand Prix parlez-nous de cette
section karting combien de membres la
composent est-ce que vous vous entraînez
régulièrement ce que vous participez à à
d'autres trophées alors dans la section
il y a un peu plus de
qui viennent de tous horizons du groupe
justement les différentes filiales de
Crédit Agricole et LCL donc LCL est une
filiale et donc j'en fais partie et je
suis dans la section depuis 2005 2006 à
peu près
une découverte j'avais toujours eu envie
d'en faire un peu un peu comme vous deux
trois fois comme ça et puis ensuite
voilà en croisant les membres qui
étaient déjà à l'époque moi je suis j'y
suis allé
rempli ou finalement c'est un bon niveau
alors on fait des courses loisirs
d'ailleurs vous me demandiez ce qu'on
faisait c'est on fait des courses à peu
près une fois deux fois par mois et
contre d'autres entreprises
d'Île-de-France ou à l'intérieur du
Crédit Agricole il y a des courses qui
sont organisées comme ça et en termes de
palmarès justement on a gagné deux fois
de suite là contre contre les autres
sections du Crédit Agricole
vous aviez déjà arpenter le circuit
Beltoise on imagine oui oui ça fait
partie des circuits où on vient chaque
année on doit on doit venir trois fois
quatre fois par an sur le circuit
deltoise donc là pour se préparer pas de
préparation particulière finalement
c'est c'était ce que vous faisiez normal
en vérité on savait à peu près comment
aller se dérouler la course de poules
mais mais la course de finale on savait
pas on l'a découvert comme vous alors
vous finissez vos tours en 54 55
secondes en moyenne c'est quoi vos
conseils pour arriver à ce temps là
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
il faut vraiment freiner comme il faut
avant le virage et ensuite commencer à
réaccélérer pendant le virage et pour
maintenir le kart et puis pouvoir
repartir on accélère pas un virage on
garde on garde le pied sur
l'accélérateur ensuite on accélère mais
on garde le moteur le moteur doit
toujours tourner un régime suffisant
pour pouvoir accélérer plus facilement
mais freiner c'est important le freinage
très très important les prochaines
étapes pour vous ce qu'il y a d'autres
déjà trop faits qui sont programmés dans
votre agenda non mais la section
organise dès samedi prochain à Beltoise
une journée un peu familiale loisir
comme ça où on invite les amis et puis
les et puis la famille on a on a on a le
barbecue sur place aussi enfin voilà
c'est c'est quelque chose de très sympa
et puis sinon après ça sera la qualité
on fait pas pendant les vacances
parce qu'elle peut pas rejoindre votre
section parce que c'est internet
de vous rencontrer
non je connais pas bien les les clubs en
général les pistes comme Beltoise ou RKC
à Pontoise propose des activités club
mais sinon on les connaît pas non sur ce
trophée qui avait fut un temps un
trophée de karting de tvfils 78
peut-être que ce serait l'occasion de le
relancer pourquoi pas voilà en tout cas
c'est lancé c'est sur la table en tout
cas félicitations à vous Fabrice canard
de la section karting du Crédit Agricole
vous étiez accompagné de juste pour les
citer de Marc et locaux et de Frédéric
Dussault qui sont aussi LCL et Crédit
Agricole et ça bah bravo à eux et bravo
à vous en tout cas c'est un plaisir de
partager cette journée avec vous
Mathilde et Nicolas je sais pas pour
vous Mathilde c'est incroyable comme
expérience
du team building enfin vous le savez ça
crée des liens ça permet d'avoir
confiance les uns aux autres non c'est
une très belle expérience
le matin en plus sur les co-conduite le
freinage tout était regroupé pour passer
une bonne journée instructive sur cette
donc première journée premier trophée de
karting de 50 ans divine c'était
vendredi dernier sur le circuit Beltoise
à Trappes petite pause à présent dans le
7 8 pour faire la connaissance du jeu
Hugo à un adolescent de 12 ans situation
de handicap originaire de Feucherolles
depuis 3 ans il développe une passion
pour les jeux vidéos de combat à un
moment de partage autour de sa console
avec ses cousins malgré ses difficultés
à s'exprimer portrait de ce gamer
chevronné avec Julien Leroy
un petit tour avec moi
un moment d'évasion de l'autre côté de
l'écran pour Hugo 12 ans prendre la
manette en main est un plaisir quotidien
originaire de Feucherolles l'adolescent
passionné de boxe aime jouer au jeu de
combat avec sa famille Super Smash Bros
ou Street of Rage 4 atteint d'une
mutation génétique sont handicap
ralentis le passage des informations
dans son corps difficulté à s'exprimer
et à se déplacer cette activité lui
permet d'être en interaction avec ses
cousins il est avec eux il est dans une
action parce que quand ils sont petits
des fois ils jouent au foot bah il peut
pas aller jouer au foot les jeux vidéo
ça fait des moments partagés ça parce
que il a pas la même vie on peut dire
qu'un enfant standard de ce qui fait que
bah c'est un moment où il est un peu
comme les autres et on joue quelque
chose comme les autres lors du
confinement en 2020 son oncle lui
rapporte une console le début de la
passion du GO pour plus accessibilité
ses parents font l'acquisition d'une
manette adaptée aux personnes en
situation de handicap d'un coup de 350
euros grandiovistique et large bouton
pour remplacer ses anciens contrôleur
Minecraft et que c'était compliqué on
avait essayé de bloquer la manette pour
pas qu'elle bouge mais les boutons sont
trop près donc on a essayé des
subterfuge on mettait des choses qu'on a
essayé des mousquetons des cordons pour
bloquer donc avec la nouvelle manette il
peut jouer à Minecraft
depuis un an tous les mercredis un
mercredi sur deux je venais chez lui et
ben on joue tous les deux et parfois il
arrive à gagner contre moi lors des
parties des environnements épurés sont
choisis par ses cousins pour permettre à
Hugo une meilleure visibilité un
divertissement permettant à l'adolescent
d'améliorer sa dextérité et son
attention
il parle avant il était un zombie qui
regardait et qui t'a fait peu sur ces
voilà je vous envoie les premières fois
où en fait vous jouez avec lui il va y
avoir besoin de taper parce que il
fallait limite au début je joue avec lui
pour justement qui se recentre et que
les personnages ils restent dedans
maintenant c'est exceptionnel si c'est
tu es à l'extérieur c'est qu'il y a trop
de choses et que ça le perturbe en fait
aimant le partage avec les autres
l'adolescent voudrait trouver un copain
pour jouer à la console avec lui si vous
aimez la bagarre Hugo se fera un plaisir
de vous défier sur ces jeux préférés
[Musique]
et on ouvre tout de suite la page sport
dans le 7 8
[Musique]
même si on a eu un bel avant goût tout à
l'heure avec le karting en tout cas
nickel et minero est revenu en plateau
pour m'accompagner dans cette partie
sport et on disait tout à l'heure on va
parler de rugby avec le plaisir Rugby
Club l'équipe senior a été éliminé en
16e de finale de Fédérale 2 une saison
exceptionnelle pour le club nous disait
tout à l'heure Thierry l'amandé qui est
le président du club et vous avez été
rejoint par Guillaume Raynaud qui est
directeur sportif bonjour allô bonsoir
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
Thierry lamandez sur le qualification
qualificatif de tout à l'heure et une
saison exceptionnelle
à tous niveaux que ce soit sur la
structure du club et les projets engagés
et puis sur les résultats sportifs tout
à fait de d'avoir perdu en 16e de finale
c'est pas un échec selon vous tirer
l'amendée non c'est un apprentissage
donc je pense qu'il faut faire mieux
l'année prochaine
nickel oui ben on a de la pub où je suis
tout au long de la saison on a vu que
l'équipe a vraiment brillé cette saison
l'équipe a peut-être raté le coche en
terminant pas deuxième peut-être vous
avez le sentiment là ou pas Guillaume
de la poule
de la saison ça vous aurez peut-être
permis d'aller un peu plus loin du coup
en tout cas de effectivement de garder
cette seconde place au détriment de
Courbevoie après encore une fois c'est
un groupe qui progresse l'année en année
donc l'expérience allait prise et c'est
surtout préparé maintenant l'année
prochaine peut-être avec des objectifs
un peu et c'est un groupe que vous
voulez garder vous allez conserver tout
le monde c'est l'objectif c'est mieux
que vous je crois que c'est la base du
club c'est le l'ambiance du club aussi
donc
ça fonctionne je vois pas pourquoi les
gens sont bien ok donc
c'est de garder l'effectif actuel déjà
c'est un premier pas aussi bien
encadrement que je joue donc c'est le
ski normalement et fait alors pour
préparer justement la saison prochaine
alors pas forcément au niveau de
l'équipe senior mais dans tout le
plaisir Rugby Club dans sa globalité
vous avez organisé une journée de
détection récemment chez les jeunes quel
était l'objectif de cette journée
promouvoir le CEL donc cel qui a été
labellisé il y a de moins de ça par la
Fédération française de rugby donc
ça se le CL le sax sur deux de
programmes donc un programme sportif et
un programme formation professionnelle
donc voilà les voilà et du scolaire donc
les portes ouvertes étaient
faites pour les joueurs issus du club et
de l'extérieur parce qu'on essaie
d'ouvrir aussi le CRL au club voisin
centre d'entraînement labellisés voilà
donc c'est un centre de formation pour
pour club amateur ce détection que vous
faites régulièrement au sein du club
attirer la Vendée on le fait tous les
ans et je dirais que après on est en
relation avec les clubs aux alentours
pour proposer puis avec des loups on va
double licence et les jeux aussi
pratiquer quoi et comment on détecte
justement les futurs potentiels par
différents thématiques proposées sur des
axes des exercices des ateliers
qui sont mis en situation donc là cette
année sur les entraînements des
catégories donc c'était les Cadets
Juniors le mercredi soir avec les
seniors juste après c'est assez
rapidement ou pas
bonjour de rugby ça se découvre assez
facilement alors le l'aspect technique
se voit assez facilement après le
potentiel généralement va faire des
paris sur certains sur certains profils
et puis c'est en cours de saison qu'on
va pouvoir vraiment réaliser et pouvoir
analyser les capacités des joueurs et
des joueuses
académie de rugby qui a vu le jour
depuis 2021 pour les jeunes de 16 à 23
ans c'est important de créer une
identité de club
des plus petits jusqu'aux plus grand
finalement ça permet également de
propose aux meilleurs éléments de rester
sur le club après c'est pas tout seul tu
as fait ce qui se fait on a quand même
beaucoup de joueurs qui partent sur le
Stade Français le Racing ou Massy mais
je dirais
on est entre les deux entre la structure
qui n'offre pas de complément de
d'entraînement et les clubs pro là on a
vraiment une sur quel soir de plus zone
dans la semaine des axes de travail
individuels qui sont proposés qui
doivent vraiment améliorer puis
permettre aux jeunes de
d'être de rester chez lui au club avec
l'esprit familial quand même parce que
c'est aussi l'une des marques de
fabrique de du plaisir Rugby Club tout à
fait de toute façon cette fidélisée
un maximum et puis surtout pouvoir à
subvenir aux futurs besoins de l'équipe
du groupe senior version comme fille
justement les filles on allait en parler
dans quelques instants la section
féminine connaît un grand boom depuis
quelques mois quelques années comment
vous l'expliquez
c'est un travail qui est fait en amont
parce que on essaye
exactement c'est un travail qui fait en
amont déjà sur les millimètres et les
canettes parce qu'on a on a un collège
donc le Guillaume Apollinaire à plaisir
où il y a une section rugby donc on a un
corps professoral là-bas qui a aussi
intégré au club et qui font un grand
grand travail pour récupérer des profils
féminins et puis après on essaye aussi
de faire pas mal d'interventions dans
les écoles dans les collèges pour
recruter et puis pareil pour alimenter
dans les années futures le groupe
féminin senior actuellement sur le
l'ensemble du club une soixantaine et
vous pourriez en avoir plus parce que là
on est avec les Panthères de Vélizy donc
en association sur l'entente sur les
seniors fait plus de 18 on est à peu
près presque 14 filles dans chaque club
donc mais bon c'est ça se passe bien
puis ça se développe quoi ils entendent
c'est une solution une bonne solution
pour justement attirer plus de féminine
avoir des gros pôles de
joueuses sur sur les clubs oui parce que
l'objectif c'est peut-être de monter en
effectif est passé de du jeu à 10 au jeu
à 15 quoi sur les sur les filles mais
comment on fait qu'on concrètement pour
vous rejoindre si on veut si une fille
derrière son poste de télévision vous
regarde en ce moment comment on fait
vous voulez sur le club le site internet
du club vous avez toutes les tous les
éléments et on a parlé plusieurs projets
là on sent concrètement où vous voulez
emmener le club dans les prochaines
années
l'objectif numéro un c'est de structurer
et d'avoir vraiment un club qui soit
moteur sur le bassin des Yvelines le but
c'est pas de faire de l'ombre aux autres
clubs c'est se servir de nos structures
et des compétences qu'on a au sein du
club pour pouvoir alimenter les clubs
autours
quelque chose à ajouter
il le vit bien donc
on le sort on le sent très investi on le
sent très investisseurs sur le sujet
parlons pour terminer de l'équipe
seniors alors l'année prochaine on aura
de beau derbivillons on aime les appeler
comme ça il y a déjà avec Versailles
c'était déjà le cas cette saison il y
aura aussi le MLS GP et prochaine qui
fait son retour en fédéral 2 est-ce
qu'on peut parler d'objectif fédéral une
des d'ici 2027 allez voilà fiction
peut-être à la barbe
une montée c'est quand même ça se
décrète pas comme ça aussi par rapport
après il faut voir aussi
des joueurs qui sont aussi des profils
un peu en fin de carrière sur certains
postes importants il faut vraiment
renouveler aussi c'est
ces postes là mais je dirais que le
l'objectif c'est de finir déjà dans les
deux premières places qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure pour avoir un
plus ou moins simplifié mais après il
faut aussi là on a appris cette année on
trouve sa prière chez nous après faut
noter qu'on a quand même été la seule
équipe même le Havre a perdu chez eux
donc
il y a quand même une vous avez gagné 28
à 27 je crois chez eux mais il y a des
motifs de satisfaction c'est quand la
reprise pour la préparation estivale
officiellement le cas après le 15 août
mais les joueurs n'arrêtent pas de la
saison il y a le site des peupliers qui
étaient internes synthétique ouvert pour
le club donc
de séances tous les permanence
ça c'est important parce que l'an
dernier on a vu que la rentrée les
joueurs étaient avaient fait de gros
sacrifice c'était déjà arrivé
après à 100% mais
merci à tous les deux d'être passé en
plateau on va bien sûr suivre la suite
des aventures du père c'est pour la
saison prochaine avec attention on
espère démonter et vous le disiez aussi
un structure plus de structuration dans
le club on va suivre ça avec attention
on va continuer de parler rugby à
Michael avec un événement qui avait lieu
qui avait donc qui se déroulait mercredi
dernier c'était droit en scène c'est ça
c'est un tournoi en partenariat avec le
Stade Français organisé au stade Léo
Lagrange des Mureaux un reportage de
Nicolas salé
3 2 1 2 le coup d'envoi de cette
deuxième édition de drop en scène et
données France Angleterre Samoa ou
encore Pays de Galles tous les pays
présents à la Coupe du Monde 2023 ils
sont représentés 8 villes linoises
participent à cet événement dont boisfle
qui voit de multiples intérêts donc
l'idée c'est d'abord de donner envie de
faire du sport
sport c'est une belle rencontre et de
pouvoir se challenger entre commune et
puis aussi effectivement puisque là on a
aussi des IME sur place donc la place
pour tous dans le cadre du sport
le respect des valeurs le partage et la
bienveillance était donc mis en avant
durant l'événement qui souhaitait aussi
avoir un intérêt culturel
[Applaudissements]
on a demandé donc aux villes aux écoles
de travailler sur le pays qu'il
représente donc drapeau connaissance du
drapeau de l'hymne national des couleurs
de leur équipe donc on voit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des il y a des
villes qui ont qui sont venues avec les
couleurs qui ont dessiné les drapeaux
qui ont travaillé sur la culture de
chaque pays c'était aussi le but aussi
de de cette opération
l'idée c'est du lait commune et les
enfants qui prennent plaisir à découvrir
ce sport tout en restant très compétitif
on est venu pour découvrir un sport
après il y a des personnes du club des
aînés pour nous donner des stratégies et
des tactiques et on tente de mettre ça
en place pour les grands gagnants un
trophée et une opportunité unique de
représenter comme il se doit leur
commune
et on passe à présent Mickaël au
résultat sport du week-end et des
derniers jours dans les Yvelines alors
on l'a vu plutôt fringants à
Roland-Garros où il était sorti au
deuxième tour face à Fritz Arthur Riner
knech est actuellement à Londres pour se
préparer en vue de Wimbledon il a joué
les qualifications du Queens la semaine
dernière mais il a été éliminé par le
Bulgare Grigor Dimitrov assez sèchement
le score 6-3-75 Arthur hinder knech
espère faire mieux sur gazon cette année
notamment à Wimbledon l'année dernière
il avait été sorti au premier tour par
Denis chapeau valov on continue par du
baseball les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux jouait ce
week-end contre l'une des meilleures
équipes de France Rouen baseball à
l'extérieur les illimonté en Russie
remporté le premier match 7-0 mais ils
se sont inclinés lors de la deuxième
partie 6 à 4 au classement mon signe
Bretonneux et quatrième de la poule A
avec un bilan de 10 victoires pour 8
défaites ils sont à égalité avec les
boucaniers de La Rochelle on a la chance
on a des talents talents yvinois il y en
a un notamment en natation il y en a
beaucoup et là en natation c'est c'est
de lui dont on va parler un grand espoir
yvelinois en des Jeux paralympiques de
Paris 2024 il en finit plus de
surprendre le monde de la natation à 21
ans à l'exportel a réussi une double
performance alors qu'il disputait les
championnats de France à Rennes avec les
valides la semaine dernière double
médaillée par olympique à Tokyo les
villes noires originaires de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye atteint
d'albinisme oculaire à profiter des
séries pour améliorer le record du monde
du papillon dans sa catégorie s13 en 2
minutes 2 secondes et 58/10 une
performance qui lui a permis de goûter à
une finale A de l'exercice au milieu des
valides et d'un certain Léon marchand il
participera dans six semaines au
mondiaux de Manchester en Angleterre à
noter également la belle performance de
Justin Delmas à 18 ans la licencier du
CNO de Saint-Germain en l'air emporté 4
médailles au championnat de France dont
les médailles d'argent en 200 mètres
brass talons également du côté de
l'aviron avec Claire Beauvais c'est ce
qu'on dit tout le temps les viennoises
claires Beauvais qui nous a fait vibrer
avec une médaille d'argent au dernier JO
était sur l'eau lors de la manche de
Coupe du Monde de Varez la semaine
semaine dernière avec sa coéquipière
Laura Tarantola toutes les deux elles
ont emporté une médaille de bronze elle
termine derrière les Britanniques et les
Américaines elles enchaîneront avec les
régates de Lucerne du 7 au 9 juillet je
rappelle que Claire Beauvais est
originaire de la région de
Mantes-la-Jolie et on poursuit avec du
handball les finales des coupes et
challenge des Yvelines se sont tenues
pendant deux jours au Palais des Sports
d'Élancourt au programme 20 matchs
organisés par le Comité des Yvelines et
le club d'Élancourt Maurepas des images
de Mélanie poquet
ramenez la coupe à la maison c'était
l'objectif de ces 40 équipes de handball
présente pendant deux jours au Palais
des Sports d'Élancourt les clubs du
département se sont réunis à l'occasion
des coupes et challenge des Yvelines
rendez-vous organisé tous les ans par le
comité de handball c'est les finales des
coupes
du haut Palais des Sports l'événement
concernait toutes les catégories des
moins de 11 ans au senior pour remporter
la compétition ils se sont tous
entraînés pour être prêt le jour J à
Élancourt
avantagés sur la défense et puis après
l'attaque et voilà tant que je peux je
viens et même si je suis malade bah je
viens quand même une compétition qui
s'est déroulée dans une belle ambiance
devant plusieurs dizaines de spectateurs
venus garnir ce palais des sports
d'Élancourt une belle récompense pour
les handballeurs handballeuses
je suis contente parce que c'est ma
première finale mais je suis aussi
beaucoup stressée j'aimerais gagner
mais ça me dérange pas de faire mais
c'est quand même je suis stressé parmi
les principaux résultats chez U18
féminines challenge Les Mureaux
longtemps porté face à l'Entente le PEC
Saint-Germain rendez-vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition dans
les images
[Musique]
oui il fait très chaud en plateau j'ai
une proposition à vous faire Mickaël on
enfile nos maillots de bain ensuite une
petite partie de volley bah allez c'est
parti en tout cas du 16 au 18 juin ils
ont fait du beach volley Le Vésinet
stade Saint-Germain volley-ball organisé
sa première édition de la Semaine du
beach-volley au programme du week-end
des tournois entre les meilleures
équipes françaises et de nombreuses
animations à reportage de Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude et Gabriel Gontier je
ne sais pas s'ils ont filmé le maillot
des plages de sable blanc une ambiance
estivale et festive tout ça dans les
Yvelines c'est assez inhabituel et
pourtant sincèrement lait a bien revêtu
des airs de Rio de Janeiro le temps de
quelques jours au stade Georges Lefèvre
du 16 au 18 juin Le Vésinet stade
Saint-Germain volley-ball organisait sa
première édition de la Semaine du
beach-volley c'est une première édition
c'était une édition que nous avons voulu
développer parce que nous voulons
vraiment faire la promotion du beach
volley sur la sur la région
Île-de-France donc le club a développé
depuis deux ans une section beacholley
et dont le cadre de cette section nous
développons régulièrement tous les ans
des tournois et en France les tournois
de beach volley sont classés par niveau
et donc après deux ans et demi
maintenant nous arrivons au top des
tournois avec ce tournoi S5 qui est l'un
des tournois les plus faciles au tournoi
le plus dotés en France aujourd'hui les
20 meilleurs équipes masculines et
féminines se sont affrontés un spectacle
de haut niveau pour les beacher et pour
cause il s'agit du plus important
tournoi national officiel de beach
volley de la saison organisée par la
ville c'est la quatrième étape du
championnat de France tous les thés
entre de mai à août on parcourt un peu
toute la France pour ces tournois donc
certes il y a pas le bord de mer mais il
y a l'ambiance il y a surtout les clubs
et tous les bénévoles qui sont très
investis pour organiser chaque tournoi
pas de bord de mer donc mets le niveau
est au rendez-vous c'est deux sœurs qui
jouait sous les couleurs du Vésinet
Saint-Germain n'ont rien lâché une belle
bataille super bataille super
intéressante à jouer
très très fier de ce qu'elle a fait
Marion comme boulot elle a défendu elle
a tout réceptionné parce que du coup ils
servent sur elle et franchement elle a
bien tenu deuxième set elles sont devant
18,14 je crois si je me souviens bien et
on lâche pas et on revient et même dans
le money time la quand c'est hyper serré
et ben
on a fait le taf
avec cet événement que le club souhaite
pérenniser dans le temps l'objectif est
également d'initier de nouveaux jeunes
qui représenteront les couleurs du club
en attendant Agathe Roland et Florine
Gosselin termine à la deuxième place
Marion et Lucie de quelle heure
finissent 5e du tournoi de Série 1
on a besoin encore d'un peu
d'entraînement je pense pour eux comme
on l'a vu en tout cas ça sent bon l'été
ce reportage avec ses cet événement
dédié au Big je voulais merci Michael
pour ces résultats sport et on va à
présent clôturer cette émission avec un
dernier coup d'oeil aux prévisions météo
de demain
tout comme aujourd'hui ce sera plutôt
nuageux dans les Yvelines avec le matin
déjà des températures chaudes lourdes 21
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 20 degrés à
Versailles et Houdan 19 degrés à
Rambouillet et conséquences le ciel sera
orageeux dans l'après-midi pas de pluie
à annoncer pour autant côté température
comptait 25 degrés dans les secteurs de
Mantes-la-Jolie et ou dans 24 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet
pas forcément de très bonnes conditions
pour le beach volley voilà c'est la fin
de ce 7 8 merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]